un impulso muy necesario para el
esfuerzo bélico de Ucrania Alemania
anunció el envío de 18 tanques de guerra
leopardos al país después de que las
tripulaciones ucranianas recibieran
entrenamiento en suelo alemán para
utilizarlos la respuesta a su pregunta
es sí entregamos los tanques leopard tal
y como habíamos anunciado Alemania
accedió por primera vez a suministrar
los tanques a Ucrania en enero tras
meses de presión sostenida por parte de
sus aliados y kiev también ha confirmado
la llegada de tanques Challenger 2 de
fabricación británica el ministro de
defensa ucraniano o lexicoff publicó una
foto en su página de Facebook de uno de
los tanques junto a otros equipos
militares occidentales describiendo el
tanque como una obra de arte militar
Reino Unido declinó hacer comentarios
pero sí confirmó que las tripulaciones
ucranianas ya estaban de vuelta en casa
después de entrenarse con los tanques en
el país los líderes occidentales también
han intensificado las críticas a la
decisión de Rusia de desplegar armas
nucleares tácticas en velarus con el
Primer Ministro neerlandés advirtiendo
tiendo a Moscú contra su uso
nosotros y nuestros aliados de la otan
estamos observando Atentamente la
situación pero se trata realmente de
retórica y Rusia sabe que las
consecuencias serían enormes y utilizar
este tipo de armas
Ucrania dijo que la decisión de
transferir las armas podría
desestabilizar velarus y acusó a Rusia
de convertir al país en un rehén nuclear